I am boom are you looking forward to  Batman in the Dark Knight Rises  I'm fully looking forward to it I  recommend everybody to go and watch this  movie it's fantastic on it is starring  me I might kick his ass to deal with it  today he's gonna have quite a fight on  his hands however being a person from a  terrorist organization we have been  training for many years in order to  achieve this one moment of chaos Gotham  will fall  what sort of training have you been  putting in for this moment  oh I start with about 20 roarings a day  but that's just me I have to insert them  via tube because of respiratory problems  but I'll probably go into detail about  that because it's very secret  you